foreign
[Music]
get away from something
Sometimes they come here looking for
something
sometimes they find it
[Music]
I'm working on this case
these men disappear 48 hours ago
this is the last Sunset before the long
night theory is they went out to watch
it
it was a weather event
yeah I'm treating this like a murder
case
how scared you have to be to run out in
the ice without any shoes
hey this is a cry
I want to work with you take a look in
the mirror
no one can stand you I'm just gonna do
this one thing work together to close
this case
that's it for the two of us yes it is
you don't really think we're gonna find
them do you either they want to believe
some Miracles
we ain't got [__] we don't have anything
sure you're up for this
this third day of dark and it's already
getting weird
[Music]
the zenith
just don't have answers
the night country it takes us one by one
it's crazy to shoot me survive